لماذا هناك من ينجح في عمله وهناك من يفشل
هناك من يتقدم وهناك من يبقى في مكانه على
كل حال لا تعتمد الحياه المهنيه على
الشهاده الجامعيه فحسب في العمل وعلى دروب
النجاح قصه اخرى تبدو والحياه المهنيه
اصعب دوما الامن الامر يكون اكثر تنافسيه
مع الاخرين في سبيل النجاح الوظيفي هذا
النجاح يلخصه موقع لينك ان في عده خطوات
وطبعا التقدم الوظيفي والتقدير العمليه
يرتبطان بقوه بالاستعداد والرغبه في
الاداء الجيد فما هو سر النجاح لتوقف اولا
مع ما قيل في النجاح الوظيفي مع علاء
الكثير من العظماء ورجال الاعمال تحدثوا
ببضع كلمات عن النجاح ومن ابرز تلك
المقولات عباره رجل الاعمال الراحل ستيف
جوبز الذي قال اتقن عملك جيدا ولا تنام
دون ان تتمه على اكمل وجه فالنجاح لا
يتوقف ويتطلب المزيد دوما كذلك مقوله
الملياردير بالجيتس الصبر مفتاح النجاح
لكي تكون ناجحا عليك ان تكون صبرا اما
الملياردير الشهير الى ماسك فيعتبر البيئه
العمليه اهم سبل النجاح حيث يقول من المهم
ان تحب الاشخاص الذين تعمل معهم واذا لم
تفعل ستصبح الحياه
ووظيفتك بائسه للغايه في حين يعتبروا رجل
الاعمال الامريكي ان بناء فريق العمل
الناجح يعتمد على الاشخاص الذين يحبون
الفوز ويكرهون الهزي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على كل من جده ينورنا المستشار تطوير
الاعمال
نبدا معك بثلاثه اسرار وانت هتعلق عليها
الموظف لازم يبادر استعد للتعلم والقابليه
للتعلم وكذلك قيم نفسك ولا تنتظر تقييم
الاخرين يعني تقييم ذاتي ما رايك بهذه
النقاط هل بالفعل هي من المتطلبات
خلينا نلخص ال 10 نقاط بثلاثه اركان
الاساسيه كلها تندرج تحت الاولى اسمها
بادر بما تحب وتتقن الثاني اسمع خذ
الموافقه قبل ان تبدا والثالثه اسمها
تواصل بذكاء عامه عشان ندمج الافكار كلها
اللي طلعت حتى من مقولات ستيف جاف ذو
مقولات الناس وغيرهم خلينا نرجع نلاقيها
كلها في بدايه البرنامج
ما استنى احد يجيء يطلب مني بدري بما تحب
ليش تحب الاثنين لازم تكون موجوده تحب
لانه في اشياء انا احب اسويها وفي اشياء
انا اذا انت تتقن الشيء وانت ما تحبه
هتقول انا خليني اتقن هذا الموضوع انا
اساعدكم فيه طب تعال ساعدتنا في ممتاز
خليك فيه طيب ليش تبقى قادر بحاجه انت ما
انت حابه دائما ابحث عن اللي تحبه النقطه
الثانيه هي انه كيف ممكن اخذ الموافقه قبل
ان ابدا ليش اخذ الموافقه ابدا ابدا
بسبب الاول انك لو تيجي تبدا بمبادره
معينه انت ما اخذت موافقه مديرك اولا
هيشوف انك ممكن تخطيته ويبدا يصير العامل
النفسي يقول لك لو سمحت وقف من قال لك
تبدا في الموضوع هذا النقطه الثانيه كمان
ممكن في اولويات احنا نبغى هذا المبادره
حقك او هذه الفكره حقتك اول اللي بادرت
فيه الان احنا عندنا اولويات اهم تاجلها
دائما لا يعني تغامر احيانا انك تتعب نفسك
وتجد نفسك وتسوي اشياء في النهايه تلاقي
نفسك ما توفقت في انها انجز الحاجه
الثالثه والمهمه جدا هي موضوع تواصل بذلك
كتاب قدمت فكره تقول انا اول ما جيت على
مكان عملي شفت انه في جالكسي في اشياء
كثير في مجال للتعديل فاجتمعت مع الاداره
قلت لهم يا جماعه عندنا هذه وهذه كلها
اخطاء سايره الحلول حاجتها 1 2 تخيلي
بالاجماع
وهي مبادره وتحب وتتقن وجاء تاخذ الموافقه
لانه ما كان في تواصل عاطفي ذكاء ليش شفت
لما بيقول لك انه المكان اللي يحبوا فيه
الناس يحبوا بعض اذا ما اشتغلت في مكان
يحبوا بعض هتحسي انه في حساسيه احيا ما
تجيء تسوي شيء لانها من الموظفين يا طيرات
واضح انه منتهي
في مواضيع اخرى بيرجع بعض
هم برصاني هو
ناس سحبت اعلاناتهم انتم تسحبوا اعلانات
يلا لازم اوفر وغير انه يطلع بديل من
الموضوع حق الاشتراكات نرجع للبيئه المحبه
البيئه المحبه هي ناس فاهمين كيف سهام
الحب كيف ميسون تحب
تشجيعه في بدايه البرنامج دائما
فهي من نوع من ايش سوت نفس كاتبه هذا
الكتاب لما جاءت تقدم مبادرتها مره ثانيه
وجهه نظر الموظف وليس صاحب العمل اليوم
عندما تركز انت ولك ان على التقييم الذاتي
من العاده الموظف ينتظر التقييم من
المؤسسه او صاحب العمل اليوم كيف يتم
تقييم ذاتي من قبل موظف تحديد الاهداف
وتحديد جدول زمني كما ذكر في كيف نقيمتنا
المقاييس اللي جالسين يقيمون عليها والعب
فيها النجاح لعبه ارقام يعني انت تبقى مني
ايش التقيمات الحضور الانصراف عليه جزء
التعاون مع فريق العمل عليه الجزء
الايجابيه لها جزء المظهر والهدام على جزء
انا اعرف هذه الطاقات كلها ابدا اشوف هذه
التقديمات اللي انت تبغاها اقول اول
الحاضرين اكون اكثر المنجزين لما ابدا
حاجه خليني اسويها بستم خليني اعملها زي
ما بتعمل بعض الشركات يعني لما تطلب مني
حاجه اجي اخذ توقيعك عليها اني انجزتها
واجيب لك نتيجه
عليها واقول لك جيبها بطريقه ذكيه لا تقول
له انجز خلاص يلا اعطيني واحده ثانيه
ايش رايك زي كده كنت تبغاها هذه الطريقه
اللي كنت تحبها كيف النتيجه كيف تنصحني
اعدل عليها ولا اطورها انت هنا بتعطي له
الصلاحيه انك تقول له انت مديري هذا
تقييمي لنفسي انا ابغى تقييمك ليا من قبل
ما يجيء تقييم نهايه السنه لما يشوفك كل
مره جيتي وجايبه له انجازاتك وبتقولي له
ايش رايك فيها انت اصلا اخدتي الموافقات
حقته على مدار السنه هايجي تقييم انت اكثر
وحده عشره من عشره خلينا نرجع للانسان
اللي كان عندها مبادره مقدمتها لشركه
ورفضوها رجعت جلست مع فريق العمل جلست مع
سهام وجلست مع خلود وجلسه مع ميسون اخذت
موافقه ايش رايكم
تاخذ كلمتين من ميسور يقول لا هو صح هذه
فكره قصدك كده
ترجع صح صح اجتمع في النهايه في الاجتماع
زي ما قالت خلود زي ما قالت س
هام الافكار
اللي احنا الكل وافق بالاجماع هنا موضوع
الذكاء لا تخلي الناس تحس بالغيره او
المنافسه معك خليهم يحسوا انك انت
بتساعدهم انهم يكونوا افضل انك انت اللي
شخص اللي بتنتجهم كلهم يرتفعوا معه في
نقطه جدا هذا زي ما قلنا المبادره بما تحب
يعني لا تقض امه لا تستطيع لما كل شويه
تقول لهم انا مبادره اعطوني اعطوني اعطوني
في نهايه المرحله هيعذروك لو ما انجزت حيث
يحاسبوك ليش قلت تبغى تسوي هذه ما سويتها
ليش ما انجزت هذه يبدا يصير الموضوع
يسموها باك فاير عليك انه انت جالس تبادل
باشياء رجعت عليك بالسلب وسيره الانسان
الغير المنجز وتقيمك ينقص شكرا جزيلا لك
من جده دائما مسترشاد تطويل الاعمال
نورتنا شكرا لك